in what way do you think
these large language models and the
thing they give birth to in the AI space
will change this Human Experience The
Human Condition
the things we've talked across many
podcasts about that makes life so damn
interesting and Rich
love fear fear of death all of it uh if
we could just begin kind of thinking
about how does it change
for the good and the bad The Human
Condition
Human Society is extremely complicated
we have come from
a hunter-gatherer Society to an
agricultural and farming Society
where the goal of most professions was
to eat and to survive
and with the Advent of Agriculture the
ability to live together in societies
humans could suddenly be
valued for different skills
if you don't know how to hunt
but you're an amazing potterer then you
fit in society very well because you can
sort of make your pottery and you can
barter it for rabbits that somebody else
caught and the person who hunts the
rabbits
doesn't need to make pots because you're
making all the pots and that's
specialization of humans is what shaped
modern society
and with the Advent of currencies and
governments and you know credit cards
and Bitcoin you basically now have the
ability to exchange value for the kind
of productivity that you have
so basically I make things that are
desirable to others I can sell them and
buy back food shelter Etc
with AI
the concept of I am my profession
might need to be revised
because I defined my profession in the
first place I something that Humanity
needed that I was uniquely capable of
delivering but the moment we have ai
systems able to deliver
these goods for example writing a piece
of software or making a self-driving car
or interpreting the human genome
then that frees up more of
human time for other Pursuits
this could be Pursuits that are still
valuable to society I could basically be
10 times more productive at interpreting
genomes and do a lot more
or I could basically say oh great the
interpreting genome is part of my job
now only takes me five percent of the
time instead of 60 of the time so now I
can do more creative things I can
explore not new career options but maybe
new directions from my research lab I
can sort of be more productive
contribute more to society
and if you look at this giant
pyramid that we have built on top of the
subsistence economy
what fraction of U.S jobs are going to
feeding all of the US less than two
percent
basically the the gain in productivity
is such that 98 of the economy is beyond
just feeding ourselves and that
basically means that
we kind of have built these system of
interdependencies of needed or useful or
valued Goods that sort of make the
economy run that the vast majority of
wealth goes to other
what we now call needs but used to be
wants so basically I want to fly a drone
I want to buy a bicycle I want to buy a
nice car I want to have a nice home I
want to tether Etc so
and and then sort of what is my direct
contribution to my eating I mean I'm I'm
doing research on the human genome I
mean this will help humans it will help
all Humanity but how is that helping the
person who's giving me poultry or
vegetables so in a way I see AI as
perhaps leading to a dramatic rethinking
of human society
if you think about sort of the economy
being based on intellectual Goods that
I'm producing
what if AI can produce a lot of these
intellectual goods and satisfies that
need does that now free humans for more
artistic expression for more emotional
maturing for
basically having a better work-life
balance being able to show up for your
two hours of work a day or two hours of
work like three times a week with like
immense rest and preparation and
exercise and you're sort of clearing
your mind and suddenly you have these
two amazingly creative hours you
basically show up at the office as your
AI is busy answering your phone call
making all your meetings you know
revising all your papers Etc and then
show up for those creative hours and
you're like all right autopilot I'm on
and then you can basically do so so much
more that you would perhaps otherwise
never get to
because you're so overwhelmed with these
mundane aspects of your of your job so I
feel that AI can truly transform The
Human Condition from realizing that
we don't have jobs anymore we now have
vocations
and there's this beautiful analogy of
three people laying bricks and somebody
comes over and asks the first one what
are you doing he's like oh I'm laying
bricks second one were you doing I'm
building a wall
and the third one what are you doing I'm
building this beautiful cathedral
so in a way the first one has a job the
last one has a vocation
and if you ask me what are you doing oh
I'm editing a paper then I have a job
what are you doing
um understanding human disease circuitry
I have a vocation so in a way being able
to allow us to enjoy more of our
vacation
by taking away offloading some of the
job part
of our daily activities so we all become
the the Builder of cathedrals correct
yeah and we follow intellectual Pursuits
artistics Pursuits I wonder what how
that really changed at a scale of
several billion people
everybody playing in the space of ideas
and the space of creations
so ideas maybe for some of us maybe you
and I are in the job of ideas but other
people are in the job of experiences
other job other people in the the job of
emotions of dancing of creative artistic
expression of you know skydiving and you
name it so basically these
again the beauty of human diversity is
exactly that that what rocks my boat
might be very different from what rocks
other people's boat and what I'm trying
to say is that maybe AI will allow
humans to truly
like not just look for but Find meaning
and sort of you don't need to work but
you need to keep your brain at ease and
the way that your brain will be at ease
is by dancing and creating this amazing
you know movements or creating these
amazing paintings or creating I don't
know something that that sort of changes
that that touches at least one person
out there that sort of shapes Humanity
through that process
and instead of working your you know
mundane programming job where you like
hate your boss and you hate your job and
you say you hate that darn program Etc
you're like well I don't need that I can
you know offload that and I can now
explore something that will actually be
more beneficial to human to humanity
because the mundane Parts can be
offloaded